the ceremony at least of home was the
highlight of many events to mark the
normandy beach landings veterans and
leaders from many countries were in
attendance among them German Chancellor
Angela Merkel French president Francois
Hollande paid an emotional tribute to
veterans in his opening speech thank you
for having been here on the 6th of June
1944 thank you for being here today on
the 6th of June 2014 you will always be
among us on this speech and in our
thoughts in a special gesture alone paid
tribute to the courage of the Germans
many of whom were forced to fight a war
which he said was not their own earlier
veterans attended a ceremony at daybreak
marking the contribution of 150,000
Allied soldiers who took part in the
d-day landings 70 years ago many of them
endured or witnessed unimaginable
suffering most of the allied casualties
occurred on a section of coastline known
as Omaha Beach a few hours later came
another High Point the franco-american
commemoration ceremony led by the French
and American presidents
thousands of white marble crosses marked
the graves of the American soldiers who
died there at the soldier cemetery in
Bayou Britain's Queen Elizabeth paid
tribute to the thousands of British
soldiers who lost their lives in the
invasion but the main event was a treaty
on the troops who landed there 70 years
ago included Free French forces who
wanted to help liberate their country
they too were remembered today